[Music]
the question is
from janissa vossian i don't know if i
said that right
the question was will we remember the
wicked things we did on the earth when
we get to heaven
no a lot of things we will not remember
um the the bible says in isaiah 65 17
behold i create a new heaven and a new
earth and the former thing shall not be
remembered not coming to mind because
they'll be remembering those things will
have no spiritual benefit there will
bring no joy you see now we will
remember them during the thousand years
because during the thousand years sin
has not yet been dealt with completely
satan is still alive with its evil
angels the wicked of the dead but this
plan of salvation is not yet complete
until christ comes back this the third
time destroys the wicked remakes the
earth then
it's all finished because as a zeal the
devil is finally destroyed the last one
that will be destroyed is satan the
earth remain new so in the thousand
years yes we'll remember but after that
no
but christ will always have the mass of
the crucifixion so there may be
something we'll remember not a life of
sin no remembrance of sin has no
spiritual value
it depresses
okay thank you
[Music]
you